le lieu est symbolique l'attaqué s'est
déroulée en fin de matinée près des
anciens locaux de charlie hebdo
deux journalistes de la maison de
production première ming faisaient une
pause cigarette quand ils ont été
attaqués à l'armé blanche
leur vie ne serait pas en danger large
périmètre de sécurité a été établi dans
le xième le quatrième et le 3e
arrondissement
des habitants du quartier sous le choc
avait l'impression de revoir un mauvais
film
j'ai entendu des hurlements terrible
donc j'étais
sur le balcon j'ouvre la fenêtre était
sur le bateau et j'ai vu une jeune dame
complètement ensanglanté qu'avec le le
cuir chevelu randonnée ici elle saignait
allure l'aisne elle tombe elle et quai
du métro j'ai une machette
avec plein de sons et des gens en train
de qui c'est un peu la panique
deux suspects ont été arrêtés en après
midi alors qu'une enquête a été ouverte
pour tentative d'assassinât en relation
avec une entreprise terroriste et
association de malfaiteurs terroristes
criminels
celui qui a été désigné comme l'auteur
principal par le procureur national est
un jeune homme pakistanais de 18 ans
arrivé en france il ya trois ans selon
le ministre de l'intérieur si le lieu de
l'attaqué est hautement chargé de
souvenirs douloureux le moment choisi ne
semble pas non plus être le fruit du
hasard
on est en plein procès des attentats de
charlie hebdo en 2015
la rédaction de charlie hebdo fait
l'objet de nouvelles menaces depuis que
l'hebdomadaire avait publié les
caricatures de mahomet le 2 septembre à
l'occasion de l'ouverture du procès
planqué de la maire de paris et du
ministre de l'intérieur le premier
ministre jean castex s'est vite rendu
sur les lieux de l'attaqué
c'est l'occasion pour le gouvernement de
la république de rappeler son
attachement indéfectible à la liberté de
la presse sa volonté résolue par tous
les moyens de lutter contre le
terrorisme
et d'affirmer à la nation notre pleine
mobilisation
la rédaction de charlie hebdo dans les
bureaux sont maintenant dans un endroit
tenu secret a publié un message sur son
site
on peut y lire toute l'équipe de charlie
hebdo ne peut que condamner cet acte
ignoble et soutenir les victimes et
leurs familles ce soir c'est dramatique
en soirée il ne faisait aucun doute pour
le ministre de l'intérieur gérald
darmanin que paris était une fois de
plus frappés par le terrorisme islamiste
manifestement c'est un acte de
terrorisme islamiste c'est une nouvelle
attaque sanglante contre notre pays
contre contre des journalistes
la france est en guerre at il ajouté il
doit mettre les moyens pour gagner cette
guerre
il s'est marié vesdun radio-canada paris